merci roger merci de l'invitation alors
pour répondre pour tenter de répondre à
la question que tu nous pose
il faut distinguer la réponse d'urgence
et la réponse politique de fond avec des
pistes d'actions pour les mois et les
années à venir
la réponse urgente et dans ce que nous
pouvons ce que nous devrions porter
comme demande politique forte à nos
partenaires les actions européennes ce
n'est jamais que l'addition des
exécutifs nationaux des parlements
nationaux et des exécutifs nationaux
c'est vraiment dans l'urgence arrivé à
se mettre très rapidement d'accord sur
la création de ces robes spot de ces
centres d'enregistrement de d'accueil de
rétention qui doit pouvoir se mettre en
place très rapidement il faut donc
l'instrument juridique et les moyens
financiers et humains
la décision semble être pris semble être
confirmée etc mais il faut vraiment
maintenant passer à l'action et donc il
ne faut pas relâcher la pression il faut
qu' il ya un instrument juridique qui
doit être votée très rapidement on
devrait être en mesure au parlement
européen parce qu'il faudra certainement
voter un instrument juridique européen
le vote est très vite et puis ensuite
débloquer très rapidement pour installer
à tout le moins ces centres
d'enregistrement dans un centre de pays
qui sont à la la bordure extérieure et
qui ont à gérer la frontière extérieure
commune donc à commencer par la grèce
l'italie et la hongrie
il faut quand même l'un des orateurs
précédents le disait dénoncé athènes la
solitaire européenne oblige de temps en
temps à faire attention à ce que l'on
dit à ne pas vexer ses partenaires et
amis mais quand même
athènes a totalement baissé les bras
hatem a totalement baissé les bras
la grèce ne contrôle plus rien et donc
devient urgent de prendre quelque chose
à bras le corps pour permettre aux
autorités grecques de faire face à leurs
responsabilités et donc nous devrons
aller certainement assurer le contrôle
de la frontière entre la grèce et la
turquie
c'est pierre lellouche qui en parlait
deuxième chose qu'il faut faire
urgemment urgemment ne pas perdre de
temps vraiment ne pas perdre de temps
c'est la liste des pays
ur à l'heure actuelle il ya une
véritable disparités hétérogénéité
fragmentation les différents pays
européens comme n'a pas de véritable
politique commune de l'asile de
l'immigration n'ont même pas une liste
commune de pays sûr nous ne considérons
pas les uns et les autres les mêmes pays
extérieurs comme des pays sûrs il faut
absolument une liste commune de pays sur
ça c'est normalement c'est de la
politique bien évidemment mais avec du
volontarisme politique on devrait pour
arrêter cela très très vite
voilà je dirais pour les mesures
d'urgence alors la répartition les
mécanismes de quotas pour l'accueil des
réfugiés le mécanisme permanent est
obligatoire de répartition bien sûr
qu'il faut envisager de ne pas faire
porter à la seule hongrie à la seule
italie à la seule grèce le fardeau de
l'accueil des réfugiés mais il faut donc
dans l'urgence à travers ces hotspots
notamment permettre un véritable tri je
sais bien que c'est difficile il ya qu'à
faut qu'on plus facile quelquefois à
dire qu'à faire mais il faut arriver
véritablement à opérer une vraie
sélection et distinguer les vrais
demandeurs d'asile des vrais faux
demandeurs d'asile et mettre en place
des procédures de sélection qui soit
efficace
et puis les pistes d'action à moyen et
long terme je pense que d'autres
intervenants ne détaillerons brice
hortefeux aura l'occasion d'y revenir
notre famille politique notre famille
politique a lancé quelques initiatives
il est important de pouvoir les
détailler tout à l'heure je voudrais
juste terminée si tu y autorise je
voulais évoquer un petit pays européen
qui ne fait pas partie de l'union
européenne je ne les riches ni en modèle
ni en exemple dans le cadre d'un bon
benchmarking c'était l'un des
engagements du président sarkozy sur
intéressant de regarder ce qui se passe
ailleurs
un petit pays qui n'est pas dans l'union
européenne mais qui est dans l'espace
schengen et qui est dans l'espace dublin
dans la convention dublin sur l'asile
c'est la confédération helvétique
à l'heure actuelle il y a dans les
textes législatifs suisses qui ont été
encore récemment révisé et durci il y à
la protection provisoire
il y à cette protection temporaire en
cas d'afflux massif de personnes
déplacées en cas de demande de
protection de demande de refuge et
maintenant
deux personnes qui viennent de zones de
conflit un c'est exactement ce à quoi
nicolas sarkozy faisait allusion en
évoquant la directive de 2001 sur la
protection temporaire ça a été
transposée dans la législation suisse
s'est appliqué alors ça n'est pas
appliquée à une énorme échelle mais la
suisse accorde pour les requérants qui
n'ont pas vocation à devenir de
véritables je dirais entre guillemets de
plein exercice
réfugiée avec l'intégralité du statut de
réfugié politique
il ya ce régime de protection temporaire
je pense que c'est une piste très
importante et très intéressante la
suisse le fait la suisse a également
pardon une procédure de accéléré 48
heures si la suisse y arrive il n'y a
pas de raison que nous n'y arrivons pas
il ya moyen en tout cas pour les
demandes qui sont manifestement infondée
il ya certainement moyen de faire comme
les suisses nous aussi si on en met les
moyens humains et financiers des délais
de traitement une procédure accélérée de
48 heures honnêtement les six y arrive
nous devrions y arriver notamment si on
fait ces hotspots européen où on
concentre les ressources humaines et
dernière chose le référendum le
référendum
voilà